THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
INSURANCE. WILL COME TO ORDER A
GOOD MORNING AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COBIT NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BIRD TO THE
PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT GET THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANTS TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND WILL ON
THE I WILL ANNOUNCE RIGHT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-4185 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. FOUR SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING ASSIST
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO BE PRESENT IN THE CHAMBER SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
BEGAN OUR HEARING. WE HAVE THREE
BILLS UP HERE TODAY INCLUDING SB
ONE FOUR FOUR FOUR BY SENATOR
BEN ALLEN PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
BEFORE WE HEAR ANY PRESENTATIONS
SOME BILLS LESS ESTABLISH A
QUORUM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WE WILL NOW BEGIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE UNTIL ALL MEMBERS
ARE PRESENT SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM AT THIS TIME. NOW WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PRESENTATIONS
ARE FIRST BILL HERE TODAY AS SB
NINE TWO SEVEN BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. BEFORE WE BEGIN
MISTER TO LET I WANT TO ANNOUNCE
TO THE CANADIAN BOB MEMBERS
THAT. THE AMENDMENTS NUMBER TWO
ON THE ANALYSIS IS BEING PULLED
FOR FURTHER CONSIDERATION AND
LYFT HAS SOME CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE LAST
MINUTE. IN ADDITION TO THE
REMAKE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON
THE ANALYSIS I SPOKE TO THE
AUTHOR AND HE HAS AGREED TO
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
REFERENCES TO THE FEES AND
CHARGES ARE CONSISTENT.
THROUGHOUT THE BILL MISTER
CHILLAYOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY SEVEN. I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE MEMBER OUTLINED.
AND AMENDMENTS OF MIND IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK THE CHAIR AND
HER STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME
DILIGENTLY AS SHE HAS. AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIR- TO CONTINUE GOING
FORWARD- BUT ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
BRINGING THE TWO SIDES TOGETHER
AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT MATTER
CHAIR. AS AMENDED- SENATE BILL
NINE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD ENTITLE
LIFE INSURANCE POLICY OWNER- IN
DECIDING WHETHER TO CANCEL A
POLICY. TO REVIEW ANY
ILLUSTRATION POLICY OR OTHER
DISCLOSURE OR INFORMATION OF ANY
KIND. THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE
A PRODUCER TO RECEIVE
COMPENSATION OR OTHER INCENTIVES
IF THE AMOUNT WAS NOT MATERIAL
TO THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
SALES TRANSACTION OF THE LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY. SENATE BILL
NINE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
ADDITIONALLY REQUIRE A LIFE
INSURANCE AGENT TO MAKES
SPECIFIC AND SPECIFIED
DISCLOSURES TO A PERSPECTIVE
POLICY HOLDER INCLUDING IF THE
AGENT RECEIVE MONETARY OR NON
MONETARY COMPENSATION THAT IS
CONTINGENT UPON SELLING A LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY OR ANNUITY. THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE AN
ILLUSTRATION OR POLICY TO
DISCLOSE FEES AND CHARGES
INCLUDING SURRENDER CHARGES AND
SPECIFIED FORMS AND WOULD
REQUIRE. A PERSPECTIVE POLICY
OLDER THE SIGNED A COPY OF THOSE
DISCLOSURES THE INSURER WOULD
THEN BE REQUIRED TO RETAIN A
COPY OF THE SIGNED AS CLOSURES
AS WELL. LIFE INSURANCE
INVESTMENT PLANS OUR LIFE
INSURANCE POLICIES OFTEN
UNIVERSAL LIFE SOLD AS
INVESTMENTS THAT CAN PROVIDE TAX
FREE PAYMENTS FOR RETIREMENT OR
FOR MEDICAL DEPENDENT CARE OR
OTHER EXPENSES. NO TAX BENEFITS
CAN BE OBTAINED UNLESS THE
POLICY REMAINS IN FORCE UNTIL
THE DEATH OF THE INSURED OR THE
EXCHANGE FOR ANNUITY. THE
MAJORITY OF THESE POLICY WILL
FAIL TO REMAIN IN FORCE UNTIL
THE DEATH OF THE INSURED OR
EXCHANGE AND THUS THE POLICY
BENEFITS ARE UNABLE TO BE
CLAIMED. THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
FOR MIDDLE AND LOWER INCOME
CONSUMERS THOSE POLICIES ARE
MOST PRONE TO FAILURE DESPITE.
CONSUMER CONTINUE TO HEAVILY
INVEST IN THESE POLICIES AND WE
MUST PROTECT THE CONSUMER IN
ORDER TO PUT IN ORDER FOR
CONSUMERS TO AVOID MAKING COSTLY
pPOLICIES CONSUMERS NEED BETTER
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE POLICY IN
THE STRUCTURE. AND THE WORDING.
THESE LIFE INSURANCE POLICIES
HAVE BECOME PROGRESSIVELY MORE
COMPLICATED OVER THE YEARS
MAKING AN UPDATE TO INSURANCE
DISCLOSURE NECESSARY TO UPDATE
THE INSURANCE DISCLOSURES ARE
NECESSARY SENATE BILL NINE
TWENTY SEVEN ADDRESSES THIS BY
STRENGTHENING THE RULES AROUND
DISCLOSURES INCLUDING AS IT
RELATES TO FEEL A STRANGE TAX
ADVANTAGES SURRENDERING OF THE
POLICY AND STRENGTHENING THE
FREE THE FREE LOOK PERIOD TO
THIRTY DAYS. TO ALLOW CONSUMERS
TO REVIEW ANY INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THEM SO THEY CAN
MAKE THE BEST POSSIBLE CHOICE
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. IN REGARD TO THE
INDUSTRY OPPOSITION. LET ME SAY
THIS I WOULD LIKE TO STATE THAT
MY OFFICE AND THE BILL'S
SUPPORTERS HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM ON THEIR CONCERN AND
THAT I HAVE ALREADY MADE AUTHOR
MEMBERS TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE-
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS INCLUDING
THE REMOVAL OF THE BEST INTEREST
STANDARD. I HAVE ADDITIONALLY
SPOKE INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE WHO HAVE RAISED SOME
SOME POTENTIAL CONCERNS WHICH
INCLUDES SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
WE WILL BE MAKING TODAY SO WOULD
LIKE TO KEEP THAT DIALOGUE OPEN
WITH THEM AND CERTAINLY THE
DIALOGUE OPEN WITH THE CHAIR SO
WE CAN ALL COME TOGETHER. TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
CONSUMER ORIENTED BILL FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE CONSUMER IS
FUTURE HIS INVESTMENTS AND-
THERE TO BIRTH INDUSTRY OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. THE
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A WIDE
VARIETY OF CONSUMER GROUPS
INCLUDING CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA- AND AMERICA. THE
LIFE INSURANCE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
CENTER THE CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM UNITED
POLICY HOLDERS AND THE CONSUMER
WATCHDOG. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL IS BRIAN PROSIGHT
BRAZILIAN. AND ON BEHALF OF LIFE
INSURANCE CONSUMER ADVOCATE
CENTER AND KIM. HOW LET. A
PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS FIRST
HAND EXPERIENCE WITH THE
PROBLEMS THAT THESE PLANTS CAN
CREATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS BRIAN WILL ALSO BE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY TECHNICAL.
ADVICE AND ONCE AGAIN KIM WHO IT
IS HERE TO GIVE US HIS OWN
PERSONAL INVOLVEMENT AND HOW
DISCLOSURE WOULD HAVE SAVED HIM
MONEY. AND PROBLEM. ACTUALLY
AFTER I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CHEER. THANK IN THE SENATE
ARCHULETA- BEFORE WE MOVE OVER
TO. TESTIFY I NEED TO HAVE
STATUS DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARING
SIX TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIRED MAY INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS IF NECESSARY ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES ALL
OTHER WISHING TO TESTIFY IT MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION. ON
THE MEASURES- I SEE A QUORUM HAS
ARRIVED SO BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH TESTIMONY IF I MAY
I WOULD LIKE TO STOP SHORT FORM
FIRST. CONSULTANCIES ALL THE
WRONG. RUBIO ISN'T RUBIO PRESS
JONES. JONES PRESENT ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA HERE EIGHT. BATES HERE
FOR JUST. DOT DOT HERE GLAZER
HERE GLAZER HERE HUESO. OUR
DAUGHTER. MELENDEZ PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO HERE BROUGHT BROUGHT
HERE RIGHT HERE WELCOME. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NOW ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM- I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
TESTIMONY. WE HELP AND SUPPORT
WITNESS IDENTIFIED WE WILL HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST WITNESS- BRIAN
BROWSE NOT BRESNAHAN FOLLOWED BY
KIM HOW LET MISTER BROWN HAD YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS BRYAN
BROSNA HAND I MEAN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LIFE INSURANCE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY CENTER WE ARE
A SPONSOR OF A BEAT NINE TWENTY
SEVEN ALONG WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. I'M AN
ATTORNEY WHO CONCLUDED AFTER
MANY YEARS OF REPRESENTING LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY HOLDERS THAT
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
PROTECT CONSUMERS WHO BUY
INVESTMENT ORIENTED LIFE
INSURANCE AND TOO OFTEN LOSE
SUBSTANTIAL PARTS OF THEIR
RETIREMENT SAVINGS BUYING THESE
POLICIES. WITH ANOTHER ATTORNEY
AND WITH VETERANS OF THE LIFE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY WE FORMED THE
ADVOCACY CENTER TO ADVOCATE FOR
STRONGER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN
THE LIFE INSURANCE MARKET. THE
THREE INDUSTRY VETERANS ON A
REPORT HAVE OVER ONE HUNDRED
YEARS OF LIFE INSURANCE-
EXPERIENCE SO OUR ORGANIZATION
UNDERSTANDS BOTH THE CONSUMER
AND THE INDUSTRY PERSPECTIVES.
SB NINE TWENTY SEVEN IS NEEDED
BECAUSE TOO MANY INVESTMENT
ORIENTED POLICIES FAIL TO
ACHIEVE THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH
CONSUMERS ARE BUYING THE
POLICIES. THEY BECOME SO
COMPLICATED THAT NO CONSUMER CAN
UNDERSTAND THEM. CONSUMERS HAVE
NO CHOICE BUT TO TRUST THE
AGENT'S RECOMMENDATION BUT THE
AGENT WORKS FOR THE INSURANCE
COMPANY AND IN MOST CASES HAS A
DIRECT CONFLICT OF INTEREST WITH
THE CONSUMER BECAUSE THEY GET
PAID A COMMISSION. BASED ON HOW
MUCH CREAM CONCERT A GREASE. NOW
THE BILL'S BEEN NARROWED SINCE
IT WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED SO
THAT IT NO LONGER REQUIRES
AGENTS TO ACT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CONSUMER. WE
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO BRING THAT
ISSUE BACK FOR YOU IN THE
FUTURE. BUT EVEN HAS NARROWED
THE BILL REQUIRES TRANSPARENCY
ON SEVERAL KEY ISSUES INCLUDING
THE NATURE OF THE H. OF
RELATIONSHIP AND COMPENSATION.
AND THESE DISCLOSURES WILL HELP
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM MAKING
THE KINDS OF BAD CHOICES THE
RESULT IN THE 8290% POLICY
FAILURE RATE. REFER TO BUY A
CONDOM IS. THAT WE'VE DOCUMENTED
FROM INDUSTRIES PERSISTENCY
STUDIES. I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
ARE TWO DIFFERENT PORTS ANTACID
TO VOTE I. S. B. NINE TWENTY SEP
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOT HEAR FROM HER NEXT
WITH. THANK YOU MAY CHAIR GOT
MORE. MY NAME IS KIM HOW WHAT. I
CAME FROM SAN DIEGO TO TELL YOU
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO HELP
PREVENT CONSUMERS FROM FALLING
INTO THE TRAP. MY WIFE AND I
FELL INTO WHEN WE BOUGHT TO
UNIVERSAL LIFE POLICIES. MY WIFE
MARIEL SUPPORTER WANTED TO BE
HERE. BUT WHEN THE HEARING TAKE
UP MOVES YOU COULD MAKE IT. SO
WE WANT TO POLICIES TO BE OUR
RETIREMENT PLAN. THE AGENT PITCH
THEM AS BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
TAX FREE RETIREMENT INCOME WHEN
YOU INVEST THE MONEY IN THE
POLICY EARLY ON. AND THEN THE
MONEY GROWS OVER TIME BECAUSE IT
INDEX TO THE S. AND P. FIVE
HUNDRED. AND THEN YOU CAN BORROW
FROM THE POLICY TAX FREE IN YOUR
RETIREMENT AND WHEN YOU DIE THE
DEATH BENEFIT PAYS OFF THE LOAN.
IT SOUNDED GREAT BUT IT TURNED
OUT TO BE BASICALLY A SCAM. THE
PLAN WHY AGES SOLD ME WAS TO PUT
THE BALL OF MY RETIREMENT
SAVINGS. IT IS THE POLICY IN THE
FIRST FOUR YEARS FOR A TOTAL OF
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND NEVER INVEST
ANYMORE MONEY AFTER THAT I PAID
THE FIRST A HUNDRED FIVE
THOUSAND BEFORE I UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE POLICY HAD MULTIPLE
FEES. THAT REDUCE THE POLICY
VALUE EVEN THOUGH THE
ILLUSTRATION SHOWED ONLY ONE FEE
. THE POLICY VALUE FELL INTO A
GOT TO FIFTY THREE THOUSAND AND
THEN THEY TERMINATED IT AND TOOK
THE REMAINING MONEY. I NEED TO
REST ARE WRAPPING UP THANK YOU.
MY RECOMMENDATION. WRAP UP HELP
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM THESE
KIND OF SCAMS TAKE VOTING FOR IT
SB NINE TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU I WILL ALLOW
A FEW MORE SECONDS PASS THREE
MINUTES TO THE OPPOSITION. NOW I
WE WILL HEAR FROM WITNESSES
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBER
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE TO STATE YOUR NAME. AND
YOUR POSITION. TO BE AN ATTACKER
WITH THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE CONSUMERS
ARE PROTECTED. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO. SPEAK DANIEL
GUTERRES ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR THIS
MEASURE HAND ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER WATCHDOG ALSO ACROSS
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY. C. NINE WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE OTHER
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
ABSOLUTELY LOSING IT IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. YOU'LL HAR AN
INDICATION YOU'VE BEEN IN PLACE
IN Q. AND AN EIGHTEEN T.
SPECIALIST WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LIFE. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- HAVING SEEN
NO OTHER- WISHING TO TESTIFY WE
WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO THE
OPPOSITION. ARE WE WILL FOLLOW
THESAME PROCESS WITH THE
OPPOSITION TODAY HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE. MATT POWERS
ARE ALSO A TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION AS SHERRY MCCUE- YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU. A GOOD
MORNING CHAIR REVIEWING SENATORS
MATT POWERS WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
SIGNIFICANT WORK DONE BY THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE. WE STILL
UNFORTUNATELY REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. AS WE HAVE CONVEYED AT
THE VERY STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
SINCE INTRODUCTION. THIS BILL
TAKES ON SEVERAL ISSUES THAT
COULD BE SEPARATE BILLS IN THEIR
OWN RIGHT WHICH IS MADE FINDING
AGREEMENT ESPECIALLY COMPLEX.
TODAY WE HAVE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME WITH THE UTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE ON ISSUES OF AGING
RESPONSIBILITIES AND
COMPENSATION. WE HAVE THE AUTHOR
IT'S A TO BEGIN WITH THE
NATIONAL CONSENSUS APPROACH FOR
NEW PRODUCTS. HOWEVER THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL WHILE
IMPROVED CONTINUES TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT DEVIATION FROM THE
RECOMMENDED AND A I SEE MODEL.
AS DRAFT TO BE A VERY STRONG
CONCERNS THE LANGUAGE WILL
CREATE AN IMPOSSIBLE COMPLIANCE
STANDARDS. WE HAVE ALSO
CONSISTENTLY CONVEYED TO THE
AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE THAT WILL
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL PRODUCT
DISCLOSURES. HOWEVER SOME OF THE
REQUIRED DISCLOSURES IN THE BILL
CONTINUE TO CONTAIN LANGUAGE
THAT IS FACTUALLY INACCURATE.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
DISCLOSURES OF PROPRIETY
INFORMATION REQUIRES CARRIERS
AND AGENTS POTENTIALLY EXCEED
THE SCOPE OF THEIR LICENSE OR-
WE BELIEVE THESE ISSUES CAN BE
SOLVED OR- AND WE HAVE PROVIDED
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. BUT UNLESS
THESE CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED WE
THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL CREATE
THE VERY THING THAT IT IS TRYING
TO FIX. CONFUSION FOR CONSUMERS
. LASTLY THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL. WILL TRIGGER DAY LUCIA
PRODUCT FILINGS THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE. THE TYPES OF PRODUCTS
CAPTURED UNDER SB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN ARE SUBJECT TO STRICT
REVIEW REQUIREMENTS BY THE
COMMISSIONER AND SOME PRODUCTS
REQUIRE PRIOR APPROVAL. BEFORE
ENTERING THE MARKET PLACE. THIS
IS ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC SINCE
APPROVAL CAN TAKE MANY MONTHS.
AND IT'S ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THAT
PRODUCTS WILL BE PULLED FROM THE
MARKET PLACE WELL THEY'RE
REVIEWED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION WILL HELP
BUT IT IS NOT A PANACEA FOR THIS
ISSUE. I WOULD AGAIN LIKE TO
REITERATE MY APPRECIATION OF THE
SENATE OR HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPROVEMENT OVER
PREVIOUS ITERATIONS BUT WE
BELIEVE WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO BEFORE IT IS FULLY BAKED.
SO THEREFORE YOU MIGHT READ WE
REMAIN IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU. MISS
THANK YOU WE HAVE LIMITED TIME
STILL ACT AS A VENUE- I WOULD
SAY IN A MINUTE. THE STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING I SHERRY
MCCUE REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE AND
FINANCIAL ADVISORS WE TO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
AND THE AUTHORS I'M INTERESTED
IN THIS ISSUE AND ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN AGREED
TO THUS FAR HOWEVER WE
UNFORTUNATELY TO REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE BILL WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
ENHANCED- DISCLOSURES WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA OF
ADDITIONAL CONTINUING EDUCATION
FOR THESE PRODUCTS. HOWEVER THE-
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A NEW SUBJECTIVE
REQUIREMENT AS IT PERTAINS TO
COMPENSATION I'M AND WE BELIEVE
THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM FOR
AGENTS MOVING FORWARD WE WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH. THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR ON FUTURE AMENDMENTS IN
THE MEANTIME WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE BILL IS CURRENTLY IN
PRINT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW MOVE OVER TWENTY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
THE STATE YOUR NAME AS MANAGER
MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF
OF PACIFIC LIFE INSURANCE
COMPANY AND THE INDEPENDENT
INSURANCE AGENTS AND BROKERS OF
CALIFORNIA WERE IN THE SAME
POSITION AS A PRIOR SPEAKERS-
OPPOSED TO THIS BLL WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK WE'VE DONE
WITH THE AUTHOR SO FAR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK. SESSION HERE
IN THE CHAMBER. SEEING NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
GET THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO WHEN CUED UP FOR PROPOSITION
. THANK YOU SO WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO- MEMBERS THAT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF NOW THAT WE
CONCLUDED ON THE OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORTERS ANY MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM PLEASE DO
SO AT THIS TIME. SENATOR GLAZERS
. THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
RUBIO AND- MY THANKS TO THE- THE
SENATOR FROM PICO RIVERA I THINK
HE WAS IDENTIFIED AN ISSUE THAT
HAS AS WORRIES AT WORRIED ME
BEFORE I WAS EVER IN THE SENATE
I WAS LOOKING FOR LIFE INSURANCE
AND TRYING TO FIGURE IT ALL OUT-
AND- HIS FOCUS ON CONSUMERS IS
RIGHT ON THE MARK IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT. THEY'RE IN THE
POSITION TO MAKE THE BEST
JUDGMENT THAT THEY CAN- AND IT
IS VERY COMPLICATED IT'S VERY
COMPLICATED ESPECIALLY WHEN-
PITCHES ARE MADE ABOUT TAX
CONSEQUENCES- THE ONE THING
THAT- CERTAINLY LEARNED IN LIFE
IS THAT UNLESS IT'S YOUR
EXPERTISE A VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
EVER SERVING ANYTHING IN REGARD
TO THE LAW- AND CERTAINLY
ANYTHING THAT RELATES TO- TAXES-
BECAUSE IT'S A COMPLICATED PLACE
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE YOUR
CONSULTING WITH THAT. I YOUR
YOUR HARD IN THE RIGHT PLACE IN
REGARD TO THE BILL- A IN
PARTICULAR I THINK THAT THE- THE
- TAKE THE COMPONENT THAT GIVES
A CONSUMER THIRTY DAYS. TO
CANCEL TO CANCEL A POLICY IS IT
SEEMS TO ME OF A VERY
REASONABLE. STEP FORWARD TO
GIVE. SOMEONE THE CHANCE TO
REFLECT ON THAT CHOICE THAT
THEY'VE MADE WE KNOW HOW.
CONSEQUENTIAL IT IS AND HOW LONG
LASTING IT CAN BE. AND I THINK
THAT'S CERTAINLY THE IMPORTANT
ELEMENT THAT I SEE IN THE
LEGISLATION. SOME OF THE OTHER
ELEMENTS MA'AM I'M STRUGGLING
WITH I REALLY AM TRYING TO GET
MY HEAD AROUND- THE IDEA OF. I
AND ME TO SAY IT AS A RELATIVE
WHAT I'M GONNA SAY NEXT. YEAH
DISCLOSURES ARE GOOD. I
TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD. BUT THE IN
THE REAL WORLD THERE CAN BECOME
A SITUATION WHERE THE
DISCLOSURES ARE SO VAST THAT YOU
LOSE ANY IMPACT ON WHAT YOU
ACTUALLY WERE TRYING TO DO I
GIVE YOU TWO EXAMPLES. WHEN I
SIGNED MY RENTAL AGREEMENT FROM
MY APARTMENT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
IT WAS SEVENTY FOUR PAGES.
SEVENTY FOUR PAGES OF
DISCLOSURES AND THEN THE REST
THAT I HAD TO GO THROUGH AN
INITIAL AND SIGN. AND AT SOME
POINT- YOU KNOW E. E. LOSE THE
IMPACT. AND I TALK ABOUT RENTING
I'M NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
OWNING A HOME AND ALL YOU HAVE
TO SIGN IN THAT REGARD. SECOND
EXAMPLE- VOTERS IN THEIR WISDOM
PASS LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW.
THAT INITIATIVE MANY YEARS AGO.
BRIAN PROPSIXTY EIGHT
DISCLOSURES. WHETHER ANY TO BE
ANY KIND OF CHEMICAL EXPOSURE
THAT A CONSUMER WOULD HAVE. AND%
WHAT DID WE SEE UNDER THAT WELL
INTENTINED LAW WE HAVE
DISCLOSURES EVERYWHERE SIXTY
FIVE SORRY I SEE SIXTY EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE. WHAT WE SEE IN THAT
REGARD. DISCLOSURES ARE
EVERYWHERE NOT JUST IN THE GAS
STATION BUT EVEN ON A- WHEN YOU
PULL YOUR SODA ADDED THAT. THE
REFRIGERATED CASE AT YOUR PIZZA
PARLOR IS A PROP SIXTY FIVE
DISCLOSURE IT'S EVERYWHERE. SO
WHAT IMPACT ARE WE REALLY HAVING
SO THERE'S THE REAL WORLD SIDE.
OF DISCLOSURE THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT IS GOING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. SO NOW. IN
THE SPECIFICS OF THE BILL. THE
IDEA THAT AT THAT THAT. A
CONSUMER IS GOING TO BE CONFUSED
WITH THE PERSON TRYING TO SELL
THEM A PRODUCT A PRODUCT. IS
BEING CONSTRUCTED STATED. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S MUCH
CONFUSION IN THAT SPACE- IT'S
ALMOST LIKE. GOING INTO A
MCDONALD'S AND ORDERING AND
THEY'RE SAYING AND HERE'S THE
CHARGE YOU'RE SAYING WHAT I HAVE
TO PAY. I MEAN. IT'S JUST A PART
OF A LIFE THAT THAT SOMEONE IS A
SELLER AND A BUYER AND THEY'RE
BEING COMPENSATED SO. I'M
STRUGGLING IN THAT SPACE FOR WHY
THAT DISCLOSURE IS SOMETHING OF
RELEVANCE. AND MEANING- WHETHER
WE'RE PAYING THAT PERSON A
LITTLE BIT OR A LOT. IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE IT'S SOMETHING THAT-
ANY AVERAGE CONSUMER IS NOT
GOING TO BE COMPLICATED NOT OVER
THEIR HEADS SO I'M HAVING SOME
TROUBLE WITH WITH THAT
PROVISION. YOU KNOW THE TAX
BENEFIT DISCLOSURE- IS A
WORRISOME PART OF THE
SALESMANSHIP THAT DOES OCCUR-
BUT I'M NOT SO SURE THAT THE
REMEDY IN THIS BILL SOLVES THAT
PROBLEM. IN THE WAY THAT IS A
HEALTHY WAY TO SOLVE IT- AND I
FEEL THE SAME WAY ABOUT THE FEES
ISSUE. THAT I LIKE THE IDEA OF
DISCLOSURE OF FEES SPECIALLY IF
THERE ARE. GOING TO BE CHARGES
AGAINST THE ACCOUNT OVER TIME
IT'S ALMOST LIKE. WHETHER THAT'S
A HOMEOWNERS FEE- OR THE REST OF
THAT THAT THAT'S A HEALTHY
THING- BUT I AM STUCK A LITTLE
BIT ON THIS PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION SPACE THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED BY OPPONENTS- AND I'M
STUCK A LITTLE BIT ON THESE
COMPLIANCE STANDARDS THAT THEY
HAVE TO EAT HERE TO SELL. A BILL
WITH A HEART IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. DOING SOMETHING
IMPORTANT IN THE AREA OF-
CANCELLATION PERIOD GOOD. BUT
SOME OF THESE OTHER PLACES I'M
REALLY STRUGGLING TO SEE WHY
WE'RE ADDING ENHANCE BENEFIT TO
CONSUMERS WHICH WE ALL HAVE IS
OUR HEART. AND I KNOW IS THE
HEART OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
FOR THAT GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU SENATOR A-
SENATOR DODD. YEAH WITHOUT
TAKING A LOT OF TIME ON THIS
TODAY AT THAT SITE IS SO SEE MY
COMMENTS WAS CENTER GLAZER-
REALLY AGREE WITH THE POINTS
HE'S MADE. I THINK WHAT YOU DO
HAVE IN THIS BILL IS. A REALLY
GOOD I THINK. LEFT IN IT ALSO
GIVES US SOME OPPORTUNITY. YOU
KNOW DOWN THE LINE AFTER CHANGE
LIKE THAT IS MADE. TO EVALUATE
THE PROGRAM GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU MADAM THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK SENATOR. JONES
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK VENTURE.
AND I ALSO- HAVE THOSE SHARE
SOME OF THOSE SAME CONCERNS AND
DETAILS ABOUT THE BILL. I DO
HAVE A SPECIFIC QUESTION
REGARDING THE AMENDMENTS. ARE
NOT PAGES SIX AND SEVEN OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THERE'S
REGARDING THE CONTINUED
EDUCATION PARAMETERS SUBDIVISION
A REQUIRES FOR AIR FOUR HOURS OF
TRAINING. HOWEVER THEN
SUBDIVISION BE MENTIONS TWO
ADDITIONAL HOURS. AND I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY IF THE AUTHOR
OR THE PROPONENTS CAN CLARIFY.
AT THOSE HOURS WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO BE COMPLETED AND WHAT CURRY.
SO IN ADDITION TO THE CURRENT
WHAT ARE THEIR CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTINUED
EDUCATION. AND IS THE FOUR HOURS
INITIAL AND THEN IT SWITCHED TO
ADDITIONAL HOURS EVERY YEAR
EVERY OTHER YEAR. OR IS IT
FOREIGN TO- IF YOU CAN BREAK
THAT DOWN FORCE- PLEASE. AT THAT
PORTION OF THE QUESTION I'D LIKE
TO. I HAVE THE- TECHNICAL-
INFORMATION. GIVEN BY THE-
ANYBODY DISEASE AND THEY DON'T
WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT I THINK
IS ALSO JUST A BROKEN HAND THAT
YOU MADAM CHAIR THAT PROVISION
WAS SUGGESTED BY INDUSTRY- SO
MAYBE THIS MAKE YOU WOULD BE THE
BEST PERSON TO ADDRESS IT UP
WE'RE WE'RE FINE WITH THAT. BUT
IT WAS NOT OUR PROPOSAL. THAT'S
MAKING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
WERE THINKING THAT WE WERE
HOPING IT WOULD BE FOR YOU FOUR
HOURS FIRST- FIRST TIME THEY
TOOK THE ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
THEN TWO HOURS EVERY OTHER
LICENSE RENEWAL MESSAGE TO YOUR
LICENSE RENEWAL SO BEFORE HOURS
UP FRONT FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
LICENSE AND GOING FORWARD EVERY
TWO YEARS TWO HOURS. SO WOULDN'T
BE SIX COMBINES THE FIRST YEAR
BEFORE AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY TO.
SO IS MY UNDERSTANDING THE
LANGUAGE IS NOT VERY CLEAR ON
THAT AND WE NEED TO CLEAN THAT
UP FOR- THIS SEEMED AMBIGUOUS TO
ME. A SENATOR JONES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND BEFORE WE
GO FURTHER I DO WANT TO
APOLOGIZE TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
SOME OF THE- I GUESS IN THE
GALLERY UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO OUR
SPRING BREAK. AND JOB THEY MOVED
OUR OUR HEARING DATE FROM
TOMORROW TO TODAY THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF LAST MINUTE-
CONCERNS BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND- BY WAY OF EXAMPLE
THAT THERE ANSWERING. QUESTIONS
FOR YOU THE INDUSTRY FOR US IN
ARCHULETA IS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
REALLY COLLABORATIVELY AND THERE
IS A LITTLE BIT OF CLEANUP THAT
WE HAVE TO DO BEFORE IT GETS TO
THE FLOOR. AND I WANT TO SHARE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES I LIKE TO
KNOW ALL THE INFORMATION UP
FRONT EVERYONE KNOWS ME HERE BUT
BECAUSE THIS IS THE LAST HERE WE
HAVE I HAVE WANTED TO GIVE A-
GENERAL LETTER THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD HOWEVER
WE'VE HAD. PLENTY OF
CONVERSATIONS IN HE HAS AGREED
TO OUR SIT DOWN WITH ME AND FIX
THOSE- THOSE LITTLE MINOR ISSUES
AND- MAKE SURE THAT WE FIX IT
BEFORE IT GETS TO THE FLOOR AND
MY CORRECT MISTRUST LEFT THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT MEDICARE
AGAIN IF I CAN JUST CUT BY THE
MOTION TODAY WILL. TO BE TO MOVE
IT TO APPROPRIATIONS IS THAT
CORRECT. OKAY CORRECT WITH ALL
OF THAT AND THE CONCERNS OVER
SHARED EARLIER FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES I'M GOING TO BE
VOTINGNO TODAY. AND- YOU KNOW
MAYBE WE CAN GET INTO A
POSITIVE. JOINT BY THEM. SENATOR
DOT IN YOU MAY PROCEED YOU HAD A
QUESTION YEAH AND I'M A MANAGER
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU MAKING
THAT CLEAR AGAIN SOME PEOPLE
WERE IN THE ROOM WHEN- WHEN
YOU'D MADE THE ORIGINAL
ANNOUNCEMENT AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY BUT I'D- YELL
LOOK LOOK FOR THE WITH BOTH
SIDES HERE AND GETTING A
AMICABLE RESOLUTION AND I KNOW
THE CHAIR IS COMMITTED TO THAT
SO THANK YOU AND THIS IS A GOOD
CONSUMER BILL AND SO WITH THAT
LIKE I SAID I'M IN. SENATOR DOT
I ALSO LIKE LIKE TO KNOW THE
INFORMATION UP FRONT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE DEALING
WITH THE SPRING BREAK AND THEN
THEY MOVED OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
AND AT THIS POINT I WANTED TO
GIVE OUR COLLEAGUE THE COURTESY
BUT I HAVE A ONE MORE MIKE UP ON
SENATOR DINO YOU MAY PROCEED
YEAH I WAS JUST GONNA SAY THAT
OBVIOUSLY THE BILL MOVES TO THE
CORPORATIONS COMMITTEE NEXT. I'M
FULLY ERIN THE AUTHOR- WILL WORK
OUT SOME OF THE ISSUES BETWEEN
NOW AND THE TOPIC COMES UP
OBVIOUSLY CENTER GLAZER AND
SENATOR DODD ANOTHER TO MAKE.
VALID CONCERNS SO HOPEFULLY- I'M
GONNA OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT HOPEFULLY ALL THESE
THINGS CAN BE BEST- BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN SELF LOOKING. FOR
DISSING THE RESOLUTION. THANK
YOU I DON'T SEE. ANY OTHER MY
STOP OF BACK TO SENATOR GLAZERS
MAY FIRST. BUT JERRY JUST
DECLARE. AND I I'VE I APPRECIATE
YOU RE STATING THAT- WORK THAT
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO DO WITH THE
AUTHOR DOES THAT INCLUDE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THAT I RAISE
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT
WAS JUST ON THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION PIECE SO THERE IS
SOME. OTHER MATTERS INCLUDING
THE ONES THAT I RAISE THAT ARE
PART OF YOUR DISCUSSIONS GOING
FORWARD OR ARE NOW. YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT MISTRUST LETTER YES
. YES WITHOUT A DOUBT OKAY ON
UNDER THOSE THAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND THANK YOU FOR THE
AUTHOR IN UNDER THOSE TERMS I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND
HOPE THAT YOU CAN WORK THOSE
THINGS THAT GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER MIKES UP SO I WILL
JUST SAY I WANT TO THINK THAT
ARE YOU ALL THE OPPOSITION IN AN
PROPONENTS OF THIS MEASURE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING. REALLY DILIGENTLY
TO BRING EVERYONE TO A GOOD
PLACE AND I WE WERE THERE BUT
ONCE AGAIN WE'RE DEALING WITH
TIME CONSTRAINTS AND MOVE OUR
HEARING BASED ON JUST TIME LINES
BUT I'M ALSO VERY COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
GET ALL THE INFORMATION AND I DO
HAVE THE COMMITMENT FROM THE
SENATOR WE SPOKE BEFORE THIS
HEARING THAT I NEED. A SOLID
COMMITMENT THAT HE WILL WORK
WITH ME SO THIS BILL SPECS
BEFORE IT COMES TO THE FLOOR
CORRECT AS CORRECT MANAGER AND
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES MANAGER THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU COLLEGE- IT IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL OBVIOUSLY.
TIME MURPHY. THE CONSUMER FEEL
THAT THEY WERE. GIVEN ALL THE
IN. I THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR US TO STEP IN. AND SEE
HOW WE CAN FIX IT. SO AS THIS
BILL GOES FORWARD IT'S GOING TO
GET BETTER. CLEARER DISCLOSURES
WHICH ARE NEEDED- CLARITY WHICH
IS NEEDED. THESE ARE THINGS THAT
TIS BILL WILL EVENTUALLY.
ACHIEVE AND SO THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE FORTUNATE TO INVEST
IN THE FUTURE. OF POLICIES LIKE
THIS. CAN DO IT WITH EASE. AND
AS YOU JUST HEARD. THAT THAT
THIRTY DAY WINDOW. TO BE ABLE TO
RESEND WALK AWAY. WITHOUT
PENALTY- IS SO VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. THAT WOULD BE IN
THERE SOUL DURING THAT TIME
PERIOD- THE POLICY HOLDER. CAN
GO AND GET LEGAL ADVICE FROM
THEIR TAX CONSULTANT. THEY'RE
TURNING. AND GO FORWARD IF THEY
WISH IF NOT THEY CAN WALK AWAY.
SO VERY IMPORTANT. THE
INDUSTRY'S BEEN WORKING WITH ME-
AND AS WELL AS THE- THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL. TRYING TO GET
EVERYBODY TOGETHER. BECAUSE THE
INDUSTRY HAS ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
YES AND YOU'VE HEARD. THAT THERE
IS. NO REASON WHY WE CAN'T GO
FORWARD. WITH SOME ADJUSTMENTS
AND I THINK THIS IS A VERY.
STORY THAT HAVE PROVIDED ME WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. WE WILL
TAKE THAT TO THE CHAIR. I WILL
BE WORKING WITH THEIR WITH MY
STAFF. AND TO MAKE SURE WHEN IT
GETS TO A POINT. IT BE- IN AND
CONCISE AND THE POINT THAT WE
CAN ALL GO FORWARD WITH IT AT
THE END. AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU MESSAGE LEAD I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR SB NINE TWO SEVEN.
MOVED BY SENATOR WESSEL-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. RUBIO HI RUBIO HI JONES NO
JONES NO ARCHULETA I'VE OCULAR
AYE BATES. BATES NOW FOR JUST.
DOT HI DODD AYE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE HUESO. WHAT I PATADA
. RICARDO HI MELENDEZ.
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BROUGHT. I BOUGHT A. THE BILL
HAS EIGHT BOOKS. THE MOTION WAS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE OF
APPROPRIATIONS AT THIS POINT I
SEE. THAT WE HAVE A FEW MEMBERS
ABSENCE WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU MISTER TO LETTER
THANK YOU BETTER HERE THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE S. B. ELEVEN OH
SEVEN BY SENATOR DODD SENATOR
DODD WHEN YOU'RE READY. YOU MAY
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- SB ELEVEN OH
SEVEN WILL HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS IN ANYONE WHO
IS HE- ISN'T. INJURED IN A CAR
pDRIVERS BY MODERNIZING
CALIFORNIA'S OUTDATED. MINIMUM
AUTO LIABILITY COVERAGE LIMITS.
LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS ON PAGES
SEVEN EIGHT NINE. OF THE
ANALYSIS THEY COULD SHARE. THE
CONSOLE FOR WORKING MY STAFF AND
I. TO REACH THIS COMPROMISE
PROCEED THAT VERY MUCH. WELL
EVERY STATE THE COUNTRY REQUIRES
DRIVERS TO PURCHASE AUTO
INSURANCE. IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
PROTECTION. CALIFORNIA HAS
FALLING DANGEROUSLY BEHIND. IN
PROTECTING OUR CITIZENS. FIFTY
FIVE YEARS AGO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE
MANDATORY AUTO INSURANCE
LIABILITY MINIMUMS AT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A SINGLE
INJURY OR DEATH. THIRTY THOUSAND
FOR INJURY TO OR DEATH OF MORE
THAN ONE PERSON AND FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR PROPERTY
DAMAGE. LET ME REPEAT THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S AUTO INSURANCE
LIABILITY LIMITS WERE
ESTABLISHED FIFTY FIVE YEARS AGO
AND HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED SETS.
CALIFORNIA RANKS AT THE BOTTOM
OF THREE BOTTOM THREE STATES
WITH THE LOWEST LEVELS OF
PROTECTION IN THE NATION. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE COST
FOR A NEW FORD MUSTANG WAS
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS.
TODAY A NEW MUSTANG WOULD COST
IN EXCESS OF THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN A DAY IN THE
HOSPITAL WOULD COST NINETY TWO
DOLLARS A DAY. WELL TODAY THE
MINIMUM HOSPITALS STAY IS OVER
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
DAY. A DRIVER MUST BE CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING THE COMPENSATION
NECESSARY TO MAKE AN INTRAPARTY
WHOLE AGAIN REGARDLESS OF THE
SIZE AND SCOPE FOR THE CAR
CRASH. IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
CURRENT MINIMUM AUTO LIMITS A
CALIFORNIA ARE FAR TOO LOW AND
ARE WELL OVERDUE FOR AN
INCREASE. TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
AND FAIR PROTECTION WE NEED TO
INCREASE THE MINIMUM OUT OF
REQUIRED FINANCIAL LIABILITY
COVERAGE FOR BODILY INJURY AND
PROPERTY DAMAGE. SB ELEVEN OH
SEVEN WOULD MODERNIZE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LIMITS TO THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A SINGLE
INJURY OR DEATH. SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR INJURY TO OR DEATH
OF MORE THAN ONE PERSON. AND AS
TO BE AMENDED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR PROPERTY DAMAGE.
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT CONCESSION
BELIEVE ME. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
AT LEAST 32% OF THE BODILY
INJURY CLAIMS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO BOOKS SEE THE CURRENT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR THRESHOLDS. THEREFORE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUCH OVER
EXTENDED CLAIMS WILL HAVE TO
RELY ON OTHER SOURCES TO BE
FULLY REIMBURSED FOR THEIR
MEDICAL EXPENSES WAGE LOSS AND
CAR REPAIRS. THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE AMENDED TO BE OMITTED SKEWS
ME SB ELEVEN OH SEVEN WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE
TO STUDY THE UNDERINSURED
MOTORIST COVERAGE TO TRY TO
DETERMINE. IF IT IS PROVIDING
THE KIND OF COVERAGE. DENTED AND
IF IT'S IF IT IT IF IT HELPS IN
INSURED WHO IS INJURED BY AN AT
FAULT DRIVER WITH INADEQUATE-
INSURANCE COVERAGE MUCH HAS BEEN
SAID ABOUT THE COST OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN WE HAVE
COMPETING ESTIMATES FROM
INSURANCE AND CONSUMER ADVOCATES
WHICH WE MIGHT ALL TAKE WITH A
GRAIN OF SALT. HOWEVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE WHICH
EXISTS TO PROTECT THE CONSUMER
HAS ALSO ESTIMATED THE COST
IMPACT OF THE BILL THAT COST
IMPACT WOULD BE ABOUT FOUR
DOLLARS PER MONTH ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE NO ONE LIKES TO
INCREASE COST. TO GO. BOTH CAN
SEARCH. LEVEL SEVEN WE MUST
WEIGH THE COST AGAINST THE
BENEFITS AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE HIGH COST OF VEHICLE REPAIR
MEDICAL EXPENSES LOST WAGES AND
OTHER FALLOUT FOR BOTH VEHICLE
COLLISION AND SMALL ADDITIONAL
COSTS FROM F. S. B. ELEVEN OH
SEVEN ARE WELL WORTH THE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION WITH ME
TODAY IS CASEY JOHNSON
REPRESENTING THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS MICHAEL MARTINEZ
REPRESENTING THE ISURANCE
COMMISSIONER- RICARDO LARA AND
DAISY SAY SO AN AUTO ACCIDENT
VICTIMS. ESPECIALLY AFTER I'VE-
THANK YOU SO ARCH. I'M SORRY. MR
DODD FORGIVE ME. BRING UP BY
HERE- NO COMMENT ON THAT WENT
OUT WEWILL NOW MOVE UP OVER TO
THOSE MACHINES UPBEAT
SUPPORTERS- PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL- HERE. SO WE DO HAVE CASEY
JOHNSON THAT'S CORRECT HERE IN
THE GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IT'S GOING TO BE
FOLLOWED BY MICHAEL MARTINEZ I
DO HAVE DAISY SAY SO BUT- WE
WILL HAVE A COMBINED THREE
MINUTES SO PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
THAT- YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
CASEY JOHNSON I'M A PARTNER AT
THE LAW FIRM OF EIGHTEEN MAKING
IN COLOGNE WITH OFFICES IN SANTA
ANA. RIVERSIDE IN SAN CLEMENTE
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO THE FOURTH
VICE PRESIDENT OF CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. I'VE
SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER
REPRESENTING INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE
BEEN HARMED YOU NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. PRIMARILY IN
AUTOMOBILE ACCIDENTS. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
DRIVERS CARRYING INSURANCE. WHEN
AN ACTIVE FINANCE RESPONSIBILITY
LIMITS IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PERSON AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER INCIDENT FOR BODILY
INJURIES. FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR PROPERTY DAMAGE. THESE
LIMITS HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED IN
FIFTY FIVE YEARS. WHEN FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY OR AN ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE AVERAGE
COST OF A HOSPITAL'S DAY SINGLE
DAY LOSS WAS NINETY TWO DOLLARS.
TODAY THAT COST CAN BE UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE
INCLUDING PHYSICIAN FEES. AND
TESTING COSTS THIS MEANS THAT
CONSUMERS EITHER NEEDED ON DEBT
. OR FOREGO NECESSARY MEDICAL
TREATMENT UNLESS THEY CAN GET
THEIR INJURIES PAID FOR BY THE
AT FAULT DRIVER OR THEIR OWN
UNDER INSURED MOTORIST COVERAGE.
WHILE ADJUSTING LIMITS TO MATCH
INFLATION WOULD REQUIRE
INCREASING THOSE LIMITS TO OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SB ELEVEN OH SEVEN SIX A
MODEST INCREASE IN THESE LIMITS.
AND ADJUSTMENTS GOING FORWARD IN
TEN YEARS TIME. THIS CHANGE WILL
ALLOW MORE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
INJURED TO BE FULLY COMPENSATED
FOR THEIR INJURIES AND WILL ALL
GIVE ALSO GIVE CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS PEACE OF MIND THAT
THEY'LL BE FULLY PROTECTED FROM
LAWSUITS IN THE EVENT THAT THEY
CAUSE AN INJURY. WE BELIEVE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES TO UNINSURED
UNDERINSURED MOTORIST COVERAGE
IS WOULD ALSO BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
. CONSUMERS AND THEREFORE S. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN CONTAINS A
PROVISION FOR STUDIES THAT WE
CAN HAVE MORE MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS ON THESE ISSUES IN
THE FUTURE. I'D LIKE TO SEE MY
REMAINING TIME IT TOO- MICHAEL
MARTINEZ. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE YOU DID HAVE TO STEP
OUT BUT OUR DRIVER ON ELEVEN OH
SEVEN AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. WE WILL TAKE A
POMPOUS AS MISTER. MICHAEL
MARTINEZ PLANNING TO RETURN. WE
NOW. AS DAISY IN THE CHAMBERS
WHAT SHE- WISHED TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MISTER MICHAEL
MARTINEZ. YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
RUBIO MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DAISY
THOUSAND I AM RESIDENT OF CHINO
CALIFORNIA I AM HERE TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL
ELEVEN OH SEVEN WHICH WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT CAR CRASH VICTIMS
ARE NOW THAT I'M PROTECTED OR
WORSE FITTING THE BILL FOR
SOMEONE ELSE'S NEGLIGENCE. ON
THE EVENING OF MAY TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I WAS INVOLVED
IN A HEAD ON CAR CRASH CAUSED BY
A DRUNK DRIVER. ON A PROMINENT
ROAD IN THE CITY OF BREA. I HAD
TO BE REMOVED FROM MY VEHICLE BY
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL AND
TRANSPORTED BY AMBULANCE TO YOU
SEE I HOSPITAL I SUFFER FROM
MULTIPLE INJURIES INCLUDING
FRACTURED SPINE RIB ELBOW AND
ANKLE. I REQUIRED MULTIPLE CT
SCANS X. EIGHT X. RAYS AND A CT
A TO MY NECK I WAS CHARGED TWO
DAYS LATER FROM THE HOSPITAL AND
REQUIRED A WHEELCHAIR FOR MONTHS
DUE TO LOW MOBILITY PRIOR TO MY
ACCIDENT I WAS INCREDIBLY ACTIVE
ENJOYED DANCING TRAVELING AND MY
JOB AS AN OPTICIAN. REQUIRED ME
TO BE ON MY FEET ALL DAY LONG MY
CAR CRASH CHANGE THE WAY LIVE TO
THIS DAY UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME.
YEAH. THE MINIMUM LIMIT POLICY
OF FIFTEEN. THOUSAND PER PERSON
AND FIVE THOUSAND FOR. DAMAGE.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. PER INJURY
BOTH MY INSURANCE CLAIMS ARE
RESOLVED BUT I STILL HAVE NOT
BEEN. ABLE HAVE NOT BEEN MADE
WHOLE. AS OF TODAY. I SPENT OVER
TEN THOUSAND OUT OF POCKET IT
DESPITE HAVING PPL HEALTH
INSURANCE AND MOTOR VEHICLE
INSURANCE. MY VEHICLE MY VEHICLE
WAS ALSO DECLARED A TOTAL LOSS.
AND SINCE I WAS UNABLE TO
REPLACE IT I WAS WITHOUT A
VEHICLE FOR MONTHS RELYING ON
FRIENDS AND OVER TO GET AROUND
MY APOLOGIES DAISY YOU NEED TO
WRAP. YES- DURING THE PERIOD AS
OF WORK I RECEIVED EDT STAY
DISABILITY BENEFITS AND LOST OUT
OF WAGES IN INCOME TODAY I
CONTINUE TO WORK BUT WITH
MODIFIED DUTIES I URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO PASS SB ONE ELEVEN
OH SEVEN TO MODERNIZE OUR
OUTDATED INSURANCE LAWS AND
PREVENT SOMEONE LIKE THE DRUNK
DRIVER IN MY CASE FROM ONLY
HAVING TO CARRY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN INSURANCE I'M SORRY
DAISY YOUR TIME IS UP. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT I AM
SORRY TO HEAR THAT THAT HAPPENED
TO YOU SO WHAT I WOULD GIVE THE
SAME COURTESY TO THE OPPOSITION
AS I ALLOWED HER TO FINISH HER
TESTIMONY BOB WE WILL NOW MOVE
OVER TO WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
. CHANGE ABI OF THE K. TEAM PART
AFFAIRS. AND CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE A MACHINIST SUPPORT.
OTHER A FEW OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY THEY
ASK ME TO ALSO- STATE SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA AUTOBODY. WE SAVE
LIVES. THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION AND CONSUMER WATCHDOG
ON SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
DANIEL. ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. C. NINE WE
WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO TESTIFYING
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN OH
SEVEN. SPEAKING TO PORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
BOOK VERSION THE LION TWENTY
FOUR. AS A REMINDER I- I'M
ASKING EVERYONE JUST TO STATE
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA PALAPA. REPRESENTATIONS
OF COMMERCE WORKS OUT THE DOOR
AND I ARE BOTH ELEVEN AND- BY.
SEVENTEEN I'M SORRY WE ARE SHE
SAID OPPOSE WE ARE DOING SUPPORT
OF THE BILL SB ELEVEN OH SEVEN
MODERATOR. PLEASE OPEN THE LINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR OF THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN YOU CAN
NOW PICK UP A QUALITY YOU FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHAIR
LANGUAGE UPDATE THE ELEVEN OR
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BY. TEN GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KELLY TODD I'M SERVING
AS A PROXY FOR THE FOLLOWING
STATEWIDE GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN INNER CITY
STRUGGLE THE TEAM THAT THE TEAM
NOT EQUITY LINE WOMEN IN
NONTRADITIONAL EMPLOYMENT WORLD
BEEN A STAR HUMAN SERVICES
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVERS
DRIVING MODE- MY YEAH FOUNDATION
BLACK BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
EIGHTY FIVE RIDERS BY CLUB THE
MEN AND NONTRADITIONAL
EMPLOYMENT WORLD LATINO HERITAGE
FOUNDATION LOS ANGELES. TRAFFIC
TRAFFIC STOP LOS ANGELES AND
NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK. ORANGE
COUNTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT NEXT. SURE WE HAVE NO ELSE
AND IT THIS TO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH HAVING FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS AT THIS TIME WE WILL
NOT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE.
FOR THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TODAY HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE DANNY RITTER I
AM ALSO- FOLLOWED BY SEREN
TAYLOR. THIS DANNY GO AHEAD AND
YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU- GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN RUBIO AND
MEMBERS THAT ANY WRITER ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ON S.
B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN- S. B. ELEVEN
OH SEVEN IS PREMISED ON HELPING
LOWERING. DRIVERS OBTAIN. READ
HOWEVER THE COVERAGE ALREADY IN
. TO ANY DRIVER IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WISHES TO PURCHASE IT THERE
HUNDREDS OF AUTO INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT ARE HAPPY TO
COMPETE FOR THIS BUSINESS.
RATHER WHAT THE BILL DOES IT
WILL FORCE CALIFORNIA DRIVERS TO
PURCHASE HIGHER COVERAGE WHETHER
THEY WANT TO OR NOT. THIS BILL
WILL DOUBLE THE MINIMUM
RESPONSIBLE RESPONSIBILITY
LIMITS. AND THIS COVERAGE THE
DRIVERS ARE REQUIRED BY LAW TO
KERRY IN ORDER TO DRIVE A CAR IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M ITS COVERS
COVERAGE THE DRIVERS PURCHASE TO
PROTECT OTHER DRIVERS- AND THIS
BILL IS FOCUSED ONLY ON THOSE
DRIVERS WHO ARE CARRYING THOSE
MINIMUM LIMITS SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND. DRIVERS CARRYING
MINIMUM LIMIT MINIMUM LIMIT
DRIVERS ARE LIKELY DOING SO
BECAUSE THAT IS THE AMOUNT OF
COVERAGE THEY CAN AFFORD TO
PURCHASE. MINIMUM LIMIT DRIVERS
ARE NOT DRIVING FANCY
AUTOMOBILES AND LIVING IN
MILLION DOLLAR HOMES SO THE
EFFECTS OF THIS BILL WILL BE
BORNE BY THAT POPULATION.
INSURERS DON'T HAVE TO GUESS
WHAT THE DOLLAR EFFECT WILL BE
ON THEIR POLICY HOLDERS WE ASK
OUR MEMBERS. TO GIVE US AN
AVERAGE PRICE INCREASE. IF THEY
TOOK THEIR EXISTING MINIMUM ONE
CUSTOMERS AND DOUBLE THAT
COVERAGE. OUR MEMBERS RESPONSES
RANGED FROM EIGHTY DOLLARS FOR
INSURERS THAT WRITE FEW MINIMUM
IT POLICIES UP TO THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
INSURERS THAT WRITE A LARGE
CHUNK OF THEIR BUSINESS AND
MINIMAL MINUTES. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CUSTOMERS WILL FACE
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN INCREASED
INSURANCE COSTS IF THIS BILL
PASSES WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEES THERE AS WELL AS HIS
WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE BILL WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THIS WILL DRIVE UP AUTO
INSURANCE RATES FOR THESE
DRIVERS WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD IT.
AT A TIME WHEN INFLATION AND GAS
PRICES ARE ALREADY PLACING
IMMENSE FINANCIAL STRAIN ON
THESE PEOPLE. FOR THESE
CONSUMERS PAYING SEVERAL HUNDRED
DOLLARS MORE FOR CAR INSURANCE
MAY FORCE THEM OUT OF THE MARKET
ENTIRELY WHICH WILL RESULT IN
MORE UNINSURED MOTORIST. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
WE ASK- FOR YOUR OPPOSITION TO
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU- NET
NEXT WE HAVE SERIN SERIN WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME SO. I ASK THAT YOU
EXPEDITE YOUR TESTIMONY THANK
YOU OKAY- I WILL TRY TO BE
BRIEF. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SEVEN TAYLOR ON BEHALF
OF THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON S. B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN
WE ARE OPPOSED TO A CONCUR WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE. MAYBE WATER
MAY BE DIFFERENT ESTIMATES OF
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE OF
THIS BILL CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT AUTO
INSURANCE RATES WILL INCREASE AS
A RESULT. AND WE SUGGEST THAT
YOU ALL GO ONLINE TO GET A QUOTE
FOR YOURSELF. IF YOU WANT TO SEE
WHAT THE REAL IMPACT THIS. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT EVEN WITHOUT THIS
BILL THERE ARE CURRENTLY
TREMENDOUS PRESSURES ON AUTO
INSURANCE RATES. AS A RESULT OF
THE INFLATION IN USED CAR PRICES
AND PARKS. AS WELL AS INCREASE
IN ACCIDENTS SEVERITY. THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS CORRECT
THAT THE POLICY TRADE OFF HERE
IS ESSENTIALLY. MORE CASH
AVAILABLE FOR ACCIDENT VICTIMS
AND ATTORNEYS TO RECOVER. VERSUS
SIGNIFICANT RATE INCREASES FOR
MILLIONS OF LOW INCOME DRIVERS.
THAT SAID WE BELIEVE THESE
ADJUSTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING
THOSE MOVE THIS BILL IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO REDUCE THE
COST PRESSURE ON CONSUMERS. AND
SHOULD THE BILL PASS TODAY WE
HOPE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS TO FURTHER MITIGATE
THOSE NEGATIVE IMPACTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE CHAMBER
YOU MAY PROCEED. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE ARMAND
FELICIANO ON THE APP GEICO WHERE
OPPOSED TO SB ELEVEN ELEVEN OH
SEVEN. A JOURNAL ABOUT. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY. HERE IN THE CHAMBER
SEEN NINE WE WILL NOW MOVE OVER
TO TESTIFYING VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR BEST MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE BRING A
PROMPT THE INDIVIUALS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN. DESPITE
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WHO WERE THE LINE
TWENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD. NOT A
JERK THANK YOU JOINT COMMITTEE
CALIFORNIA SENATE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE TWO MORE
LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBERS TO
THE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN.
BY TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. OKAY MY
NAME IS OUT WALTER CONTRARIES
I'M AFRAID LEADER AN ORGANIZER.
MR WITH THE PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH
IN THE ORGANIZATION CULTURE IDEA
AND WE'LL CALL IN THE PO. THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT
CALLER. LIKE. TWENTY NINE. BY
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS RED AND
WHITE WILLIAMS WITH A NEW
GENESIS MINISTRIES IN STOCKTON
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO A
BILL NUMBER ELEVEN ZERO SEVEN.
THANK YOU MODERATOR ANY OTHER
CALLERS WAITING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. NO AND YOUR MANAGER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVING HEARD
ALL DISCUSSION I WANT TO THANK
THE SUPPORTERS AND THE
OPPOSITION FOR SPEAKING HERE
TODAY WE WILL NOW BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CHAMBER SENATE ARCHULETA YOU MAY
PROCEED. YOUR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AS IT WAS SO NOTED THAT-
THIS PROVISION WAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN AND- AS CO AUTHOR I WOULD
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
AND WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
REPEAT TIME IT ALSO LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR WORKING
SO CLOSELY WITH THE CHAIR AND
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN TURNING
THIS BILL INTO SOMETHING IS SO
TERRIBLY NEEDED AND WE CAN HEAR
STORY AFTER STORY HOW A PEOPLE
WERE UNDER INSURED AND- THE TO
RECTIFY THAT SO I FULLY- AS FOR
AYE VOTE IN REQUESTED WE
CONTINUE- ON TO THE NEXT AND I-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE I THINK
I SEE- SENATOR ROB YOU MAY PRESS
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU KNOW
I WAS PLEASED TO HEAR THE
TESTIMONY TODAY REGARDING THE-
AVERAGE PREMIUM INCREASE FOR
THOSE- IMPACTED. OF THE QUESTION
I ASK VERY EARLY IN THIS
PROCESS- NOT TO THE AUTHOR BUT
TO OTHERS AND WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR
ANYTHING ABOUT WAS THE-
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA OF THOSE
IMPACTED BY THIS CHANGE THAT WAS
A QUESTION I ALSO ASK YOU VERY
EARLY IN THIS PROCESS- BECAUSE
THAT WAS ALSO. TO ME. I WOULDN'T
KNOW I AM SENDING THAT THE
LOWEST OF THOSE THE LOWEST
INCOME OF THOSE. WHO ARE
REQUIRED TO. THE PURPOSE SEVEN.
INSURANCE FOR THE OPERATION
VEHICLE HAVE ANOTHER OPTION- IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING. BASED
ON THIS- TESTIMONY REGARDING THE
AVERAGE PREMIUM INCREASE OF
WHETHER IT'S EIGHTY DOLLARS OR
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU RUN THE MATH
ON THAT IF MY MATH IS CORRECT
THAT TRANSLATES TO ABOUT SIX
DOLLARS A MONTH. AT THE LOW END.
OR A TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A
MONTH. AT THE HIGH END AND I
SIMPLY DO NOT THINK THAT THAT'S
TOO MUCH TO PAY- TO OPERATE A
MOTOR VEHICLE ON THE ROADS AND
STREETS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT OTHERS ARE COMPENSATED
WHERE THERE IS NEGLIGENCE OR
OTHER ACTION ON THE PART OF THE
DRIVER THE MOTOR VEHICLE SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND I THINK THE OTHER
BRING IT FORWARD. THANK YOU ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO MAKE COMMENTS
OR SPEAK I SEE SENATOR GLAZERS
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK THANK YOU
CHAIR RUBIO- CERTAINLY NO ONE
WANTS TO- TO TAKE ACTION TO
INCREASE COSTS BUT YOU KNOW
GOODNESS GRACIOUS LOOK AT OUR
WORLD TODAY AND- COSTS ARE GOING
UP EVERY EVERY LEVEL AND REALLY
IMPACTING OUR CITIZENRY IN
SIGNIFICANT WAYS AND I THINK WE
ALL FEEL THAT. THAT WERE IN THAT
PAIN THAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
SO I KNOW I'M TRYING TO EXAMINE
THIS BILL. AS OBJECTIVELY I CAN
BECAUSE NO ONE WANTS TO RAISE
RATES OKAY SO THEN. THE QUESTION
REALLY IS DO WE HAVE A
DYSFUNCTIONAL MARKET PLACE
WHERE- WHAT PEOPLE THINK THEY'RE
GETTING REALLY ISN'T WORKING AND
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT THIS HAS BEEN IN
PLACE. I RISK THAT THAT HELP.
THEM THAT STILL DOESN'T ANSWER
FOR ME THAT CENTRAL QUESTION
WHICH IS THAT. IF A REQUIREMENT
A MINIMUM BECAUSE WORSE OR
SETTING AN EXPECTATION THAT IS
WHAT IS REQUIRED TO DEAL WITH
THE MOST COMMON. OR THAT THE
AVERAGE OR WHATEVER- COSTS OF.
IN. THEN WE MAY HAVE A DATE YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S A CENTRAL
QUESTION FOR ME SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION THE AUTHOR WOULD BE-
JEFF TWO QUESTIONS THE FIRST ONE
WOULD BE COULD YOU SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE OF THE AVERAGE CLAIMS IN
THESE CATEGORIES GIVE US A SENSE
OF WHETHER- THE MINIMUMS ARE
REALLY COVERING THAT THE BULK OF
WHAT'S REQUIRED IN THOSE
ACCIDENTS. QUESTION NUMBER ONE.
SENATOR DONNELLY WANT TO RESPOND
TO THAT YES WATER IF MICHAEL
MARTINEZ IS STILL IN- YES YES.
IF HE'S COMING TO THE MY-
WELCOME MICHAEL MARTINEZ YOU MAY
PROCEED. YES THANK YOU- TO RUBIO
. AND MICHAEL MARTINEZ BEHALF OF
COMMISSIONER LARA AND DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LOTTE IS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND DOES APPRECIATE THE-
OF THE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN OUT TO THE BILL
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS IN REGARD
TO THE QUESTION ABOUT- THE- I
WHETHER CURRENT EXISTING LEVELS
OF COVERAGE. DO ARE ABLE. NAMES
ACCORDING TO DEPARTMENT STAFF
ARE ESTIMATES. STATE THAT
APPROXIMATELY 32% OF THE BODILY
INJURY CLAIMS AND 30% OF
PROPERTY DAMAGE LIABILITY
CLAIMS. WILL EXCEED THE CURRENT
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LEVELS
IN EXISTENCE TODAY THE
THRESHOLDS TODAY AND THAT'S WHAT
A DEPARTMENT STAFF. HAD
ESTIMATED FOR THIS YEAR OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND SO JUST
FROM- IN REGARDS TO. THE
DEPARTMENT STATISTICS WE DO
BELIEVE THAT AT LEAST NEARLY A
THIRD OF CURRENT COVERAGE TODAY.
MOTORISTS WILL EXCEED THE
MINIMUM LIMITS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION I
DO- SO YOU'RE SAYING ONE ONE OUT
OF THREE POLICY HOLDERS WHO
THINK THEY'RE GETTING COVERAGE
BASED ON WAS AT TWENTY TWENTY
TWO DATA- ARE NOT. GETTING THE
COMPENSATION THEY THOUGHT THEY
WOULD GET TO COVER THEIR THEIR
INJURIES IS THAT CORRECT. L. AS
SENATOR YES THE I WOULD SAY THAT
THE COURT INDOOR ESTIMATES THAT
CLAIMS. WILL EXCEED THE POLICY
HOLDERS CURRENT FIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE MINIMUM ONE THAT SPECIALS
TODAY AND IS THERE ANYTHING
ANYTHING ON THE REGULATORY SIDE
THAT IS IN YOUR POWER TO DATE TO
DEAL WITH THAT PROBLEM. I WILL I
WILL CHARGE THAT CAN CHARGE MORE
YOU CAN AUTHORIZE GREATER RATES
FROM INSURANCE COMPANIES WITH IS
THAT IS THAT SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
. I BEG YOUR PARDON SENATOR IT'S
A BIT HARD ON THE ACOUSTICS IF
YOU CAN REPEAT JUST THE LAST.
SENTENCE THAT YOU STATED I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND I
APPRECIATE YET THE CHALLENGES
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS THANK YOU
FOR- IN DURING THAT. I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT IS HAS IS IN A
POSITION TO DEAL WITH THAT
PARTICULAR PROBLEM IN OTHER
WORDS. WHEN INSURANCE COMPANY
COMES IN AND ASKS FOR. THEIR
RATE INCREASES FOR EXAMPLE-
WOULD YOUR DECISION REGARDING
RATE INCREASES CHANGE THAT
PROBLEM THAT YOU JUST IDENTIFIED
WHERE ONE OUT OF THREE. INJURED
PARTIES IS NOT GOING TO BE
COMPENSATED FOR THEIR INJURIES.
I WOULD SAY THAT UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE THE
DEPARTMENT IS COMMITTED TO
APPROVING ACTUARIAL SOUND RATES
AS REQUIRED UNDER PROPER ONE OF
THREE WHICH DOES STATE.THAT NO
RACHEL BE APPROVED OR REMAIN IN
EFFECT WHICH IS EXCESSIVE
INADEQUATE OR UNFAIRLY
DISCRIMINATORY WE DO BELIEVE
THAT GIVEN THE IN THE FURTHER
MEN AND TAKE TO THE MEASURE TO.
HAVE A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
DATE WILL ALLOW FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
A PROCESS INTERN FOR INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO PROVIDE- UPDATED
RATE FILINGS. IMPLEMENT S. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN AND GIVE THEM
THE TIME TO- PROVIDE WHAT THEY
BELIEVE WOULD BE NEEDED TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE RATE TO ME S. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN AND GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT THAT TIME TO PROCESS
THOSE NEW LIMITS UNDER S. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN. RIGHT SO WHAT
I'D HEARD YOU SAID IS IT IF THIS
BILL IS ENACTED INTO LAW THAT
THERE IS A PROCESS IN PLACE
THAT. THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY CAN
COME AND ASK FOR RATES TO DEAL
WITH THOSE HIGHER OBLIGATIONS
BUT MY QUESTION IS DIFFERENT.
WHETHER THERE'S ANYTHING IN THE
POWER IN THE APARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TODAY. TO DEAL WITH
THIS CONCERN THIS DOES THE
FACTUAL. DISCLOSURE THAT YOU
HAVE PROVIDED TO US WHICH IS
THAT A THIRD OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE INJURED ARE GOING TO GET
COMPENSATED TO THE LEVEL OF ITS
REQUIRED. IS THERE ANY
REGULATORY ACTION THAT YOU ARE
IN A POSITION TO TAKE ABSENT A
CHANGE IN THE LAW. TO DEAL WITH
THAT PROBLEM. OR WERE LEFT
WITHOUT WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
REQUIREMENT FOR A LOT CHANGE TO
DO SO. THANK YOU FOR BEING ABLE
TO RESTATE THAT QUESTION AND I
WOULD SAY THAT UNDER EXISTING-
THE DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING
AUTHORITY IS THAT- AND AS STATED
IN COMMISSIONER SUPPORT LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE. IS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TO CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS TO CONSIDER
PURCHASING HIGHER LIABILITY
LIMITS THAN CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
IN ORDER TO HELP ENSURE THEY
HAVE MORE ADEQUATE COVERAGE WHEN
THEY'RE INVOLVED IN A COLLISION
BECAUSE- THERE ARE SOME
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. A STEP AWAY
FROM FINANCIAL RUIN THEY DO NOT
HAVE V. D. V. LIMITS NEEDED TO
COVER CLAIMS IN ORDER TO MAKE
THEM WHOLE AND FOR INJURED
PARTIES HOLE AND PROPERTIES THAT
THAT ARE. OF THERE ARE ALSO
AFFECTED SO YES WE DO- DO VERY
AGGRESSIVE EDUCATION OUTRAGE.
BUT ONLY BUT THAT CAN ONLY GO SO
FAR SO PLEASE KNOW THAT WE DO
UNDER EXISTING. IS THE CURRENT
RATE PROCESS THERE IS THE
CURRENT. OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
THAT UNDER COMMISSIONER LOT IN
THE DEPARTMENT WE DO VERY
AGGRESSIVELY AND REGARDED
INFORMING ENCOURAGING CONSUMERS.
TO PURCHASE HIGHER LIABILITY
LIMITS AND THAT. CAN VERY WELL
BE THE CASE FOR. A GOOD MAJORITY
CALIFORNIANS BUT JUST KNOW THAT-
THAT WE DO BELIEVE THAT IN
ADDITION THIS IS THIS BILL
ANOTHER. TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO
HELP CONSUMERS THANK YOU SO ITS
DEPARTMENTS VIEW THAT EDUCATING.
CONSUMERS IS NOT RESULTED IN
PEOPLE BUYING POLICIES AT HIGHER
LEVELS THAT WOULD MORE
ADEQUATELY COVER. IT YES SIR.
AND THAT WHEN YOU- PUT IN I'M
LOOKING AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IS LETTER WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT ONE OUT OF THREE
NOT BEING COMPENSATED TO THEIR
INJURY CLAIMS THAT INCORPORATES
THAT EDUCATION EFFORTS THAT-
INSTEAD FOR PEOPLE TO CARE
HIGHER POLICY LIMITS. THAT
SPEAKS TO- THE SITUATION AS YOU
FIND IT NOT WHAT YOU'D LIKE IT
TO BE THAT RIGHT. YES ACCORDING
TO MY DEPARTMENT A STAFF FOR A
LOT MORE- INVOLVED AND THIS
LEVEL OF. OF AND EXPERTISE IN
THIS PARTICULAR FIELD OF
INSURANCE YES AND FINALLY AND
MAYBE THIS IS A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS EXPERT. WITNESS
WHICH IS THAT. OUT WE DON'T
ALWAYS LIKE TO FOLLOW OTHER
STATES IN THE COUNTRY- WE LIKE
TO SET OUR OWN PRACTICE- BUT
PERHAPS AT TIMES WE MIGHT LEARN
FROM WHAT OTHER STATES ARE
DOING- AND IN THIS CASE- THIS
ISSUE OF FIVE. COSTS AND
LIABILITY IS SOMETHING THAT-
YOU. KNOW BORDER- PREVENTS COULD
YOU I SPEAK TO- WE'RE CALIFORNIA
IS IN THE NATIONAL. SCALE OF-
THESE KINDS OF MINIMUM FIREMAN
AND IF WE'VE LEARNED ANYTHING
FROM. FROM THAT THOSE FINDINGS-
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OTHER
STATES. TENER DOT YOU MAKE
RESPOND TO THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WHERE THE BOTTOM THREE.
OUT OF FIFTY STATES AND IT YOU
KNOW IN THE UNITED STATES. AS TO
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM. FROM
OTHER STATES- I DON'T HAVE THE
DATA ALL YOU KNOW ON THAT
SPECIFICALLY. BUT I KNEW I DO
KNOW THAT THAT SITE. TO DO THE
MATH FORTY SEVEN OTHER STATES
HAVE. LARGER LIMITS THAN THAT
THAN WE DO. AND DO DOING THAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND DO WE
KNOW FINAL QUESTION WHICH IS DO
WE KNOW- AND WITH ANY DATA ON
THE YOU KNOW THE CONCERNS BEING
RAISED. THAT THE UNINSURED
MARKET PLACE IS GOING TO GO UP
RIGHT BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN'T
AFFORD THE HIGHER RATES. DO WE
HAVE ANY EVIDENCE THAT TO KNOW.
WHETHER THAT HAS OCCURRED IN
THESE OTHER STATES IN WHO WHO
WAS THAT WHO WAS BORN THE BURDEN
OF THAT. WHAT WAS INTENDED TO BE
A POSITIVE THAT TURNS INTO A
NEGATIVE. IT ALL WAIT AND SEE IF
ANYBODY GOES UP TO THE MIKE BUT
I WOULD JUST SAY. WE'VE ALREADY-
IT KNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS GOING TO
RAISE THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE
SAID FOUR DOLLARS A MONTH THAT'S
LESS THAN FIFTY. DOLLARS A YEAR.
I DIDN'T PRACTICAL TO- THE LIKE
A COUPLE OF START. WATER IN A
ONCE A- WORKING IN THE CHIEF
SMALLEST WHAT TO. LOOK AT NOBODY
WANTS EXTRA PRICE TODAY
INCLUDING ME- THE INFLATION
PRESSURES EVERY THAT'S WHY WITH.
THE CHAIR- WAS- INSISTED UPON
HAVING A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS BILL SO WE'RE NOT
CONSUMERS ARE NOT FEELING THIS-
YOU KNOW THIS YEAR DURING- YOU
KNOW WE'VE GOT A COUPLE MORE.
WAS A TWENTY TWENTY FIVE BRIAN
YEAH SO WE GOT TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION.
YOUR DATE ON THIS SO HOPEFULLY
WE'RE BEHIND THIS INFLATIONARY
PERIOD AND NOT MAKING IT A
SIGNIFICANT- ISSUE BUT THIS IS
LET ME JUST SAY. FOR FOUR
DOLLARS A MONTH IT DOUBLES THE
COVERAGE. AND I WOULD ALSO GO
FURTHER TO SAY. THIS PROBLEM
EXTENDS NOT ONLY FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE BUT I WOULD CHALLENGE
ANYBODY WHERE MOST THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM. TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOUR LIMITS ARE. IF YOUR.
INSURANCE ASIAN IS ASK YOU TO GO
HIGHER- I. PAY ATTENTION I HAD
IDEA I WENT DID. A SURVEY WITH.
FRIENDS OF MY- THEY'RE ALL
BUSINESS. ATTORNEYS INSURANCE
AGENTS INSURANCE AGENT NEW OF
COURSE THE INSURANCE AGENT WOULD
DO WHAT NOW. BUT NOBODY ELSE
KNEW. WHAT THEIR COVERAGESWERE
WHERE THEY WERE MINIMUM. NO
INSURANCE AGENT EVER ASK THEM
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THE STUDY
PORTION. OF THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU AND WITH
THE DISCRETION OF THE CHAIR THAT
I KNOW THAT THE CENTER DIDN'T
HAVE A DIRECT ANSWER TO MY
QUESTION IF THERE ARE EXPERTS
FROM EITHER SIDE TO KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT.I THINK WE WOULD
BENEFIT FROM HEARING THAT. IN
THE CASE OF FORTY SEVEN OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE THE HIGHER
LIMITS. DO WE HAVE ANY DATA THAT
SHOWS HOW THAT HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN WHO HAS BEEN
AFFECTED BY IT. AND I'D LIKE IT
IF THE CHAIR IS IN AGREEMENT BE
ABLE TO HEAR FROM THEM ON THAT.
SO I WILL ASK ANYONE THAT'S-
I'VE BEEN A GALLERY THAT. IF
ANYONE HAS INFORMATION LIKE TO
SHARE I'D GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT THIS
POINT. I SEE DANNY COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE DO YOU HAVE THAT DATA
THAT YOU WANT TO SHARE. SO I
DON'T HAVE THE DATA ON ME BUT I
WILL SAY THAT- WE- I THINK BOTH
SIDES CAN POINT TO VARIOUS
STATES WHERE WE'VE SEEN AFTER A
BILL LIKE THIS IT'S PAST. AN
INCREASE IN UNINSURED MOTORISTS-
AND A VERY AND EITHER A STEEP
INCREASE IN THE OVERALL COST OF.
AUTO INSURANCE BUT THE SPECIALLY
IN THE SEGMENT. OF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE CARRYING THIS LEVEL OF
COVERAGE. AND I'M HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH. US SENATOR
GLAZER ON SPECIFIC FIGURES. EACH
OF THOSE STATES THAT YOU KNOW
WE'VE SEEN THIS PAST IN THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS. OKAY I WILL NOW
CONCLUDE- THE PARTICIPATION FROM
OUTSIDE. I WILL TURN IT OVER ON.
CENTER GLAZER. THE THAT COUNTRY
YOU'RE QUESTION I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO SENATOR RON YOU MAY
PROCEED. I KNOW WE HAVE A
CALLING THE NEEDS TO GO VOTE
BUT- I WOULD JUST LIKE TO GET A
STRAIGHT ANSWER FROM THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER. DOES THE
COMMISSIONER HAVE THE AUTHORITY.
TO INCREASE THE MINIMUM
INSURANCE LEVELS REQUIRED IN THE
STATE OR IS THAT THE PURVIEW OF
THE LEGISLATURE I THINK THAT WAS
MY COLLEAGUES QUESTION AND I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE ANSWER.
HE'S COMING TO THE MIKE MICHAEL
MARTINEZ WOULD YOU PLEASE
RESPOND TO NUMBER TEN IS. THIRTY
IS NOT NOT. THANK YOU VERY. OKAY
I KNOW THE SOME OF OUR- ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO RUN TO THE
COMMITTEES AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE- I WILL JUST SAY REALLY
QUICKLY- IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE WE DID. A SIT DOWN YOU
KNOW. QUITE A BIT AND NOT ONLY
WITH AUTHOR BUT THAT WILL BE OUR
SUPPORTERS IN OPPOSITION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET TO A MIDDLE
GROUND. I DID HAVE COST PRESSURE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AUTHOR AGREED
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION AND-
THIS IS A BILL THAT CAN CONTINUE
TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS AND I'M VERY
CONFIDENT AS I SPOKE TO THE
AUTHOR THAT HE WILL CONTINUE TO.
TO BE OPEN MINDED AND RIGHT NOW.
HE'S TAKING A LOT OF MEN. WE
SHOULD. SELL A WORK. THERE IN A
REAL GOOD PLACE WHERE WE- SPEAK
YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT MOTOR
IS CONSUMERS ARE. TAKING CARE OF
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE COST
PRESSURES CITY OF. INFLATION AND
OTHER ISSUES SO. I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO YOU CENTER DOT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR. THANK YOU. I HAVE- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION TO THE BILL SENATE
ARCHULETA MOVES THE BILL- A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL. RUBIO I
. RUBIO HI JOE. JOE KNOW OUR
JULY. ARCHULETA I BATES NO BATES
NO REPORT. DOT DOT I LATER BY
GLAZER I WAIT. WITH A I FORGOT
OF. RICARDO I MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
POURTANT. PORTANTINO I BROUGHT
HI BROUGHT HI. THE BILL HAS
EIGHT VOTES FOR THREE AGAINST
EIGHT FOR THE MILK MOVES
FORWARD- BEFORE I KNOW SOMEBODY
HAS TO LEAVE TO GO TO VOTE I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO WOULDN'T
CONSENT CALENDAR IF WE- AND I'M
SORRY FOR THE EXPEDITED SPEECH
HERE BUT I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU
GET TO YOUR YEAH COMMITTEE
HEARING RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A BILL
SB ONE FOUR FOUR FOUR BY CENTER
BEN ALLEN PROPOSED FOR CONSENT-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. RUBIO HI.
RUBIO I JONES. ARCHULETA ARDUIN
I. EIGHT JONES I GOT THAT RIGHT
YEAH BATES FIVE EIGHT I PORCHES
OR JUST I DOT. DOT HI PLEASE.
GLAZER I WAS A WITH A I
RETIREMENT. YOUR TOTAL HI
MELINDA. MELENDEZ I PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I THOUGHT ROTH HI
BILL HAS TWELVE THAT'S TWELVE
BOTH THE BILL IS OUT WE WILL. I
BELIEVE WE OUR ROLE OPEN ON ONE
BILL OUR A MEMBER TO ARRIVE AT
CHAMBER OF S. NINE TWO SEVEN BY
SENATOR I LET ACT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BORJA BORDERS NO
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NOT. THE BILL
HAS EIGHT VOTES FOR FOUR AGAINST
. THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT I'M
AT THIS POINT I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO JOINED US
HERE IN PERSON AND REMOTELY FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY OR TESTIMONY IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND BY ENCOURAGE YOU IF YOU
DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY TO GO TO
OUR WEB AND PLEASE SELL SO IT
COULD BE RECORDED YOUR COMMENTS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO US ONCE
AGAIN WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AND THIS
COMMITTEE IS NOW UNDER.